hi so I'm shalota Fraser a second year
PhD student in computational
neuroscience and today I want to answer
some questions that you guys have
actually asked on YouTube about
neuroscience and computational
Neuroscience such that you hopefully can
become a little bit a better
computational neuroscientist so I in
general want to make these type of
videos a little bit more these q a type
of videos because I really enjoy making
them and I also sometimes feel a little
bit bad that I don't answer all your
questions because I think some of the
questions are quite difficult and need a
little bit more explanation so I don't
always feel comfortable typing it up so
I hope you really enjoyed this video and
if you have any other questions that I
haven't answered during the video please
put them down in the comments below and
perhaps I will answer them next month so
the first question I got is from Daniel
to nacho and he asked hey I'd like to
know if you could shed more light on
computational Neuroscience as a master's
degree so maybe some of you know but
I've done the cognitive Neuroscience
Masters agree with a specialization in
computational Neuroscience but they call
it the track in natural Computing and
neurotechnology but this basically comes
down to computational Neuroscience so we
studied the following courses so we had
computational Neuroscience machine
learning we also had Hands-On
Neuroscience so this were these kind of
anatomy type of classes quantitative
brain networks complex adaptive systems
AI for neurotechnology and cognition and
complexity and as someone that has done
this master I think the biggest benefit
actually from this particular monster
was that it was a research master so you
had about a year full of courses and
then you had a year where you could
actually do some research with a lab and
I think this really taught me what
research is all about and also the type
of skills that you need because I think
doing a lot of courses in computational
Neuroscience for example you kind of get
a feeling that there's a lot to learn
and that it's really fun and everything
but I think doing the actual work of
finding those things out is quite
different and I think the earlier you
can get some research experience the
better and that's also why I would not
necessarily recommend people to do a
master's program so I think the only
reason I would do a master's program is
if I knew my job required it or if I
knew that I could get some research
experience and I wanted to become a PhD
student and the type of master's degree
that you do them for computational
Neuroscience I don't even think it
necessarily has to be in computational
Neuroscience if you want to be a PhD
after the next question is by Daniel he
asks I'm starting soon my bachelor in
computer science and Neuroscience and
what is the best attitude or system to
go about reading scientific articles
like those you shared have any tips or
suggestions okay I think maybe at a
certain point I want to make a full
video about how I go about reading
articles and I do know different people
have different preferences so I'm just
gonna give you my system so the rate I
do it is I first try to find the
Articles right and I've said this before
I do this for example on Twitter where I
follow a few of my favorite researchers
and they usually publish a lot of their
work I also get articles from the lab
that for example my professors recommend
that I read and there are also a few
historical articles almost that are just
really remarkable in the field and that
almost everyone has read so that's
usually how I go about finding them and
then the second step is quick reading
them and the way I do it is that I
usually Mark papers with this app called
insta paper and it doesn't always work
well for paper so I do have to give this
little caveat but insta paper is really
nice I use it to Mark articles I run to
read also just little snippets on the
internet that I think may be interesting
and then it's all in this almost news
type newspaper type of format and then I
have the app insta paper actually on my
iPad so it looks like this and so for
example right now I'm reading this
article from nature obtaining genetic
insights from Deep learning um so the
way I would go about it is I would
usually read the abstracts I would look
at the figures so all the figures
um that are in the paper and I see if I
understand them and usually if I
understand them that kind of means that
the paper doesn't contain anything new
so yeah that's usually how I do it on
Insta paper and the fact is that I also
have my insta paper linked to my notion
so I have it linked to to read wise so
on my notion I then have all the notes
that I made on Insta paper automatically
on my notion which I personally really
like yeah so this is quick reading them
and sometimes I find that in the papers
by quick reading them that I really see
that oh this is a super important paper
for my work or I can learn something
really new or it's just in general a
really interesting paper and then I
usually
um put it over to sotero and so tarot is
this paper manager app it's kind of like
this is reference manager app but I
really like it to really deep read
papers and by that I just mean fully
reading all the papers really marking
all the parts that I find interesting
and usually also what I do is I also
look up the code that people use
um really take a look at the algorithms
and see if I can implement it but as you
can hear this takes really long like
deep reading a paper or fully reading a
paper takes me almost three hours maybe
so that's why I almost never do this
like most papers I quick read and I
think I quick read a paper and anywhere
between 10 and 30 minutes so I can read
a lot of papers that way and the Deep
fully reading I only do with like one
paper maybe every month like really not
that often it this happens so the next
question is from yashi and I actually
got this question a lot as well they ask
hey is there any difference between
computational neuroscience and cognitive
science or cognitive neuroscience and I
think this in general is kind of a hard
question because I don't personally like
to you really Define the borders of
Neuroscience I think some people prefer
to call themselves a cognitive
Neuroscience a cognitive neuroscientist
versus a computational neuroscientist
but there have been many Papers written
about this and for example one is from
nature that I will show you real quick
so they really show in this figure for
example the distinction of the cognitive
science part computational science part
and artificial intelligence and in their
paper they State cognitive science
starts from computational Theory
decomposing cognition into components
and developing representations and
algorithms from the top down and
computational Neuroscience proceeds from
the bottom up composing neuronal
building blocks into representations and
algorithms thought to be useful
components in the context of the brain's
overall function so you can kind of see
these three building blocks where AI is
also also a part of it but I don't
really fully agree you with this this is
like a really clear distinction that if
you do computational Neuroscience you
only do bottom up and if you do
cognitive Neuroscience you only do top
down but personally I actually think
they're so deeper almost philosophical
reason why people will call themselves
one versus the other and I personally
really like
um from the computational brain what
they say about computational
Neuroscience so they say the expression
computational and computational
Neuroscience reflects the role of a
computer as a research tool in modeling
complex systems such as the network
ganglia and braids okay using the word
in that sense one could have also
computational astronomy or computational
geology in the present context however
the word primary force is its
descriptive quantitation which here are
the tokens the deep-seated conviction
that what is being modeled by a computer
is itself a kind of computer and that's
not to say that computational
neuroscientists think that the brain is
a computer that's of course not true but
they do see a lot of similarities right
and I also think in general for example
I work in neuroimaging and I think this
is almost in the border between
cognitive sciences and computational
Neuroscience and AI I think neuroimaging
computational Neuroscience is almost
fall exactly in the middle of all of
these Fields so yeah I think in general
it's just really hard to have clear
borders between these fields but if you
want to say I think classically usually
when you go from a bottom up approach
and you really try to model single
neurons that was usually considered
computational neuroscience and then when
you go from a top-down approacher you
really try to think of behavior and make
more psychological models for behavior
for neuroscientific models for Behavior
that's cognitive Neuroscience then the
next question is from Sam amazing video
Charlotte could you please recommend any
request for people like me who are doing
research in a neurobiology of language
so for people that don't know
neurobiology of language is under to
understand cognitive and neural
organization of human language skills so
personally um I know in the donors
there's of course the group from Pizza
Hut and here's a on I will put an online
lecture from him down below that's the
core and Beyond in a language ready
brain I think that's quite a good
summary of the the field also if you
look at his website the neurobiology of
language at the donors there are a lot
of different groups that are doing
research in it right now so I think you
can look up those groups and look at the
paper State written so you have for
example neural computational models of
language neuropragmatics information
structure dialogue Etc I also like
personally discourse from Coursera and
it's not specific for language but it
has there is one week where they discuss
language or the neurobiology of language
the Neuroscience of language and that's
understanding the brain the neurobiology
of everyday life and I think the teacher
is really nice she explains it really
well it is a little bit surface level so
if you're already a little bit more
advanced or you already know quite a lot
about Neuroscience I think it may be a
bit too easy and if it is too easy I
also like this course called the human
brain on MIT they also have one talk I
think one or two specifically about
language and lastly I came across this
super interesting paper from nature
lately which is called an investigation
across 45 languages and 12 language
families reveals a universal language
Network and I personally find this
really interesting because usually our
language studies are done with people
that speak eurocentric languages such as
like English French German just because
it's usually easier to reach these type
of people but these scientists really
made an effort to include as many
language families and languages as
possible in their study such that they
could make more comprehensive
conclusions for the entire human
population and not just Europe and
America okay and then the last question
and this question I get a lot as well
and maybe I'll do a video about it but
how do you read Neuroscience books
sequentially read or thinking read where
you take notes
um so let's take a neuroscience book
that I refer to quite a lot the
computational brain by Patricia
Churchland I got this book because it
was on sale that's the only reason I got
it and as you see I bookmark quite a lot
and the way I read these types of books
is usually when I'm researching
something I don't want to have the
general consensus of the field and then
I usually look at a book and I know kind
of in my head which books have which
topics and I look at that book to kind
of see what the general consensus of the
field is because as I have said in a
previous video a lot of these
Neuroscience books are a little bit
outdated because the field moves so fast
that some of the things that are stated
five years ago are already not true but
it is usually good to get a general
feeling of what kind of things are
considered accepted Neuroscience
knowledge so I do think for example this
book the principles of Neuroscience has
almost every topic you can think about
in neuroscience and it's a really good
place to start for example if you want
to do research in Ascension you read
their chapter on attention and see what
kind of terms are you used
um which kind of papers are quoted these
kind of things so I almost never read a
book back to back I almost always just
read specific chapters that I find
interesting so yeah these were the five
questions I picked for this week I hope
you enjoyed this kind of video a little
bit and if you have any question you
want to have answered for the next month
when I perhaps make another video like
this please let me know down in the
comments below and I will try to
carefully answer your question as well
and otherwise have a lovely week and see
you next time bye